oh actually okay I gotta I got through
eighth grade and we we're on the East
Coast trip and I roomed with like these
three Korean dudes I didn't really know
that well but they were cool guys but we
gotta share a bed all four no no we have
two beds and he started cuddling me in
the middle of the night like he's Korean
Korean is he crazy yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I couldn't
sleep but there are lines of
homosexuality it's different uh
did your dick grow up oh let me touch
your butcher okay
[Laughter]
he's making me grab it now yeah I'm not
doing it that's part of their machismo I
love how you saw an opportunity
[Music]